la parole est à Monsieur Francis
Delattre pour le groupe Union pour un
mouvement populaire
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
dans les lois de finances de cet été
rectificatif le gouvernement vous avez
prélevé 13 milliards d'impôts et taxes
supplémentaires sur les entreprises et
dans le même temps alors que les marges
étaient au plus bas que les
investissements des entreprises
s'écroulaient il était pour le mois
Béarn de supprimer dans l'urgence le
dispositif de la TVA antidélocalisation
qui transférait 13 milliards d'euros de
charges sociales aux entreprises vers la
fiscalité ce qui aurait produit ses
effets dès le premier octobre 2012 pour
améliorer la situation financière de nos
entreprises vous avez essayé de réparer
cette belle vue en reprenant l'analyse
partiellement du rapport Gallois sur la
nécessité d'un choc de compétitivité
devenu en fait un pacte avec le crédit
d'impôt pour la compétitivité l'emploi
malheureusement aujourd'hui cette
urgence n'a reçu aucun début
d'application et ceci m'amène madame
à vous poser trois questions au-delà du
verbiage d'une instruction fiscale
pouvez-vous nous préciser les modalités
de son emploi pour l'année 2013
ce dispositif de 20 milliards d'euros
était devait être financé à parité par
la fiscalité que nous connaissons et par
10 milliards d'économies que nous ne
connaissons pas Madame ministre
aujourd'hui pourvu nous préciser nous
indiquer les contours de ces économies à
défaut ce pack se réduirait un habile
plan de communication
quid ensuite des 19 autres propositions
du rapport Gallois notamment quid des
propositions que le rapport appelait le
complément indispensable au choc de
compétitivité et en particulier les
mesures pour renforcer les fonds propres
des entreprises pour sortir leurs
investissements dans une période où tout
le monde sait que le crédit bancaire se
fait rare avec les applications des
directives de balle 3 qu'en est-il
madame Linux de la réorientation vers
les PME et et
PEA des plans d'épargne en action et
plus généralement du développement de
l'actionnariat des PME dans un cadre
fiscal non pénalisant visible par
rapport à d'autres placements en vous
rappelant qu'aujourd'hui les
investisseurs qui soutiennent l'économie
réelle sont de 4 millions de personnes
alors qu'ils étaient il y a deux à trois
ans 7 minutes très bien la parole est à
madame la ministre
le président monsieur le sénateur le
crédit un peu compétitivité emploi comme
j'ai dit tout à l'heure c'est
effectivement un effort de l'État pour
les entreprises de 20 milliards d'euros
j'insiste sur ce chiffre puisque vous
faisiez référence vous-même à 13
milliards d'euros de la TVA qui reposait
sur le consommateur et donc les
consommateurs français nos concitoyens
sont distinguer d'ailleurs parmi ceux
qui sont les plus riches et ceux qui
sont les plus défavorisés donc le Crédit
Impôt pour la compétitivité emploi vise
à créer comme le demandait d'ailleurs
Louis Gallois dans son rapport un choc
de confiance et à permettre à nos
entreprises de renouer avec l'emploi et
avec l'investissement donc je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure ce sera tout d'abord un
allégement de 12 milliards en 2013 le
temps de la montée en charge puis de 20
milliards en 2014 de charges patronales
qui pèseront sur le travail et qui
seront ainsi alléger les PME je l'ai dit
pourront solliciter le pré-financement
du crédit un peu compétitivité emploi
directement auprès de la BPI ou d'Oséo
d'abord en cédant la créance crédit un
peu compétitivité emploi qu'elles ont
sur l'état les banques commerciales
pourront elles aussi avec la garantie
d'Oséo assurée se préfinancement c'est
un mécanisme extrêmement simple il
suffira aux entreprises de calculer le
montant de crédit impôts auquel elles
ont droit et puis de présenter ce calcul
à la banque publique d'investissement ou
à une banque commerciale pour obtenir le
prix financement du crédit un peu
compétitivité emploi vous m'interrogez
ensuite sur les dispositions en faveur
des fonds propres des entreprises il ne
nous a pas échappé évidemment dans le
diagnostic que nos entreprises souffrent
d'un taux non seulement d'un taux
d'autofinancement qui est plus faible
que celui des PME je parle des PME en
particulier mais ça vaut pour toutes les
entreprises que les autres PME
européennes mais également qu'elles ont
des difficultés dans l'accès au fonds
propres que l'industrie du capitaliste
est insuffisamment ou du capital
développement est insuffisamment
développé en France et là encore la
banque publique d'investissement qui
sera dotée de 40 milliards de plus de 40
milliards de fonds propres sera une
réponse puisqu'elle permettra c'est la
banque des PME elle permettra de
répondre à la fois en crédit et en
apport de fonds propres aux difficultés
de financement des PME donc vous avez là
une réponse extrêmement concrète à
comparer à je ne sais pas quel bilan du
gouvernement précédent enfin s'agissant
de l'épargne vers les PME le président
de la République s'est engagé à
construire un produit d’épargne PEA PME
destiné à orienter l'épargne des ménages
et par qui est abondante en France vers
les entreprises vers les PME merci
Monsieur Delattre
nous apprendrons moins de choses
intéressantes c'est que c'est la BPI qui
va financer en partie des dépenses qui
sont quand même visiblement de
fonctionnement puisque c'est des
remboursements
avancés le problème c'est le problème de
la créance parce que la créance avec les
conditions
les conditions qui ont été imposées à
l'Assemblée nationale font que la
créance n'est pas certaine donc ça
posera des problèmes juridiques en fait
le volet le plus important selon moi
c'est quand même les fonds propres et de
dire que c'est uniquement à travers la
BPI moi je pense que c'est un travail
l'actionnariat et par une privée qu'il
faut essayer de réorienter les choses et
que je pense que en termes de force de
frappe c'est de que les contribuables
que les actionnaires et un peu de
lisibilité c'est ce qui demande d'abord
et et de nous expliquer que c'est
uniquement par fond public que nous
allons redoter l'ensemble de nos
entreprises des moyens suffisants je ne
pense pas enable le ministre